le sujet des relations entre les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
et l'état n'est pas nouveau et je sais
que les sénat s'y intéresse depuis
longtemps nous avions d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion d'en discuter notamment dans
le cadre de l'examen de la proposition
de loi sur la nationalisation des
autoroutes
l'année dernière les concessions
autoroutières dont on peut rappeler
qu'elles ont été autorisés par la loi du
18 avril 1955 ont contribué à développer
un réseau de routes à haut niveau de
service et de sécurité pour l'usager la
france dispose d'un réseau autoroutier
de plus de 9000 km de voies concédé
alors lorsque ce modèle a émergé nous
étions à une époque où la france avait
un retard en termes d'équipement et nous
considérer que la voiture était le moyen
de transport privilégié
il est clair qu'à l'époque les
considérations environnementales n'était
pas central les sociétés autoroutières a
été au départ pour l'essentiel public et
leurs bénéfices permettait de financer
des investissements dans les transports
on est parti de concessions qu'ils
avaient une durée de jeu quoi une
trentaine d'années puis ensuite on a
largement recouru à la doucement afin
notamment de financer le développement
de liaisons interurbaines moins
rentables bien que bénéfique pour
l'aménagement du territoire la doucement
a eu pour effet de doubler les durées
des concessions par rapport à celles
initialement prévues dans les années 60
peut aussi noté qu'historiquement les
sections à péage était loin des
agglomérations
elle servait essentiellement aux trajets
occasionnels des particuliers et au
transport de marchandises sur longue
distance du fait de l'extension des
agglomérations et des changements de
mode de vie
on constate que beaucoup de français
aujourd'hui sont amenés à utiliser
l'autoroute pour leurs déplacements
quotidiens
cela pose notamment la question de
l'acceptabilité du modèle du péage pour
ce type de trajet dans le même temps le
modèle d'une infrastructure financée
entièrement par l'usager
un avantage dans un contexte où on sait
que l'acceptabilité de l'impôt est elle
aussi discuté un mot peut-être sur la
privatisation des sociétés d'autoroutes
en 2005
cette décision a conduit par
construction a privé l'état des
dividendes qui était jusque-là affectés
aux investissements dans les
infrastructures de transport
je pense qu'on peut s'étonner que cette
évolution n'est pas été précédée d'une
révision des contrats
contrairement à ce que l'on observe
généralement dans ce qu'on appelle les
actifs régulés
ces contrats des contrats des sociétés
pas des concessions historiques ne font
pas l'objet d'un recalage périodique de
la rentabilité entre l'autorité
concédante et le concessionnaire
puis ces contrats qui était donc conclu
entre l'état et des sociétés d'économie
mixte qu'il contrôlait régissent
désormais ses relations avec des
sociétés cotées dans la logique est
forcément différente et je crois que le
déséquilibre et des interrogations sur
les relations entre l'état et les
concessionnaires d'autoroutes vient de
là cela explique les relais les
questions récurrentes qui sont posées on
peut néanmoins souligné que ce modèle a
tout de même évolué vers une plus grande
transparence suite notamment aux travaux
de l'autorité de la concurrence
nous sommes aujourd'hui à un peu plus de
dix ans de la fin des premiers contrats
de concessions historiques dont la durée
aura d'avenant en avenant finalement été
de l'an de 70 ans
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est légitime
de réfléchir à la presse moi je suis
convaincu que si on veut rester sur un
modèle concessif il faudra comme pour
les autres actifs régulés introduire des
clauses de revoyure pour s'assurer qu'il
n'y a pas de seront habilitées je suis
également convaincu qu'il faut un
régulateur fort et en tant que ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
je plaide aussi pour que les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes accompagne
le développement des mobilités propre
sur leur réseau que ce soit par l'import
l'implantation de bornes de recharge des
incitations en faveur des usagers en
covoiturage ou un véhicule propre toile
avec quelques mots je pouvais vous dire
en propos liminaire merci madame la
ministre
donc vincent de l'est notre rapporteur à
la rolls merci merci monsieur le
président merci madame la ministre
donc effectivement je vais peut-être
avoir deux séries de questions
et puis ensuite les connect qui voudront
s'exprimer bien sûr pourront le faire
je voudrais revenir sur sur trois points
dans un premier temps d'abord votre
parcours qui est un parcours qui nous
intéresse à un triple à triple titre
c'est à dire tout d'abord un parcours
chez un concessionnaire puisque vous
avez travaillé pour le groupe eiffage
ensuite comme directrice de cabinet
de madame royal et puis ensuite comme
ministre comme ministre de tutelle donc
peut-être nous dira un petit peu aussi
vous trouvez bien que un fonctionnaire
puisse effectivement avoir ce type de
parcours d'abord être dans
l'administration de l'équipement je
crois que vous avez commencé à
l'équipement et ensuite se retrouver
dans un groupe privé
et puis ensuite être ministre de tutelle
de ce groupe parmi d'autres mais avec
avec des concessions donc est ce que
vous trouvez que c'est bien est-ce que
vous pensez que ça devrait évoluer ou à
ce qu' il faut rien changer à sa ça
c'est la première question la deuxième
elle a trait aux à la décision de gel
des tarifs autoroutiers de fin 2014 2015
la décision qui a été prise j'aimerais
vous nous disiez comment cette décision
était prise par qui sachant que les
contrats prévoyaient et prévoit toujours
d'ailleurs des augmentations régulières
chaque année est-ce que co comment ça
c'est fait concrètement est ce que c'est
le premier ministre est ce que c'est
la ministre en charge à l'époque qui a
pris cette décision
j'aimerais j'aimerais savoir et puis
quelle a été votre rôle dans le hall
c'est un petit peu mais je pense que
c'est bien que vous le rappeliez votre
rôle dans la discussion et dans la
négociation du protocole de 2015 du plan
de relance autoroutier et des
contreparties qui ont été introduites à
l'époque
de quelle façon quel a été votre rôle
est de quelle façon vous avez tenu
informé la ministre madame royal qui a
signé ensuite le protocole et considérez
vous que ce protocole était tu étais une
bonne affaire pour l'état et pour les
usagers puisque pour moi l'état et les
usagers ça se confond de l'état n'existe
pas en tant que tel en fait c'est à la
fois les usagers et les contribuables
qui forment l'état et donc est ce que
pour vous cet accord était une bonne
affaire pour cette première série de
questions précises madame la ministre je
vais vous demander maintenant procéder
est de donner vos réponses merci merci
sur un porteur est-ce que vous pouvez
reformuler votre première question sur
la succession des fonctions voilà le
fait d'avoir travaillé dans un groupe
privé qui gérait des autoroutes etc etc
et qui avaient des contrats en tout cas
dont les filiales avaient des contrats
avec avec l'état et ensuite de vous
retrouver en position de tutelle
paramore par rapport à une position dans
laquelle vous avez une des successeurs
est en fait vous êtes en tutelle ensuite
qu'est ce que qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
alors ça m'inspire qu'il ya des règles
dans ce domaine là de conflit d'intérêts
et qu' il vous aura pas échappé que j'ai
dû
travailler chez eiffage comme vous le
rappelez je crois de 2007 à 2008 et que
j'ai pu intervenir en tant que
directrice de cabinet de madame royal de
2014 à 2015 et que j'ai pris des
fonctions de ministre en 2017 voyez donc
il ya des règles qui exprime qu'on peut
pas passer sans délais d'un poste à
l'autre et ça me semble raisonnable
ça me semble raisonnable d'avoir ces
règles et en même temps je pense que
c'est important que des gens qui
exercent des responsabilités soient de
temps en temps en train d'aller voir
comment ça se passe ailleurs voyez moi
j'apprécierais beaucoup que les
fonctionnaires de mon ministère par
exemple qui ont vocation à échanger avec
des entreprises avec des collectivités
n'est pas uniquement un parcours au sein
de l'administration d'état
mais sache comment fonctionne une
collectivité par exemple en y ayant
travaillé et sachent comment fonctionne
une entreprise est la meilleure façon de
le savoir
au delà des livres c'est d'y avoir
travaillé donc je pense que c'est
important qu'on soit capable d'occuper
des fonctions des postes qui soit
diversifiée
ça permet de créer de la fluidité et de
mieux se comprendre de comprendre quel
est le point de vue de chacun et je
pense que ça fait effectivement c'est
bénéfique pour tout le monde
modulo les règles évidemment qu'ils
doivent s'acquérir du lot les règles
évidemment s'appliquer mais voyez entre
2008 où j'ai quitté eiffage et 2014 va
vous enfin c'est tout à fait conforme
aux règles qui existent
merci madame la ministre question ce
suivante de notre rapporteur on dit en
question s'est elle c'était la décision
de geler les tarifs pour l'année 2015 en
contradiction avec les contrats que nous
avions avec lesquelles a été la
motivation qui a pris la décision
comment ça s'est passé
ouais non à part donc sujet moi
peut-être que je trouve votre micro
alors si une décision qui a été prise
par ségolène royal
vous savez c'est des questions qui
reviennent régulièrement régulièrement
on est agacé de devoir faire des hausses
de tarifs et régulièrement on
préférerait pouvoir s'affranchir des
contrats donc c'est ce que la ministre
de l'époque a décidé de faire simplement
on est dans un état de droit et quand on
a des contrats à un moment donné on est
rattrapé par le fait que les contrats
s'applique je pense que c'est important
parce que si on devait être dans un pays
dans lequel l'application des contrats
est aléatoire
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'entreprises qui
viendraient s'installer en france donc
je pense que c'est bien d'être dans un
état de droit donc quand on prend des
décisions de gel comme elles ont été
prises à l'époque ça un effet boomerang
et in fine et l'usagé l'art payés par
des augmentations qui sont maintenant
incluse sur je pense que la dgitm vous
le dira mieux que moi mais sur plusieurs
années à la fin l'usagé clairement n'est
pas gagnant donc je pense que ça montre
que face à des contrats ont pour on
pourra revenir sur le fait que c'est le
paradoxe de tous et allongement
successifs qui ont été réalisés c'est
que face à des contrats dont les règles
sont celles qui ont été conçus dans les
années 60 ou 70 et qui ensuite d'avenant
en avenants ont été prolongées comme je
le disais avec des concessions qui
auront finalement deux fois la durée la
face aux règles telles qu'elles sont
écrites dans ces contrats qui s'imposent
comment dire cédé à l'impulsion qu'on
peut avoir de dire zut c'est agaçant ces
augmentations de tarif n'est pas dans
l'intérêt des usagers
excusez moi je repose la question donc
simplement pour être bien clair c'est
ségolène royal qui a pris la décision
tout seul de geler les tarifs
il n'y avait pas d'accord du premier
ministre il y avait pas eu de discussion
interministérielle précédentes il n'y a
rien eu elle elle a simplement décidé
comme ça je sais pas sur quelles
motivations
en dehors de dire qu'effectivement
n'augmente pas mais enfin bon on
n'augmente pas quand il a un contrat est
un contrat on applique de compte assez
je comprends pas très bien comment ça
c'est prix est ce que c'est elle toute
seule qui a pris cette décision là au
sein du gouvernement
alors comment dire je pense qu'il faut
se remettre dans le contexte de l'époque
j'imagine que vous l'avez bien en tête
c'était un contexte dans lequel les
relations étaient particulièrement
tendues avec les sociétés
concessionnaires
puisque enfin il y avait d'une part
merci de leur passé là comme la
chronologie
en fait on a vu une succession de
décisions dans les relations entre
l'état et les collectivités et les
sociétés concessionnaires qui avait une
fille n'ait débouché sur une situation
tendue qui est venu on va dire
cristallisé l'avis de l'autorité de la
concurrence
évoquant une sur rentabilité des
concessions mais sa remontée au début du
quinquennat précédent au moment où il y
avait eu une décision d'augmenter la
redevance domaniale sans compensation ce
qui s'était traduit par un contentieux
lancé par les sociétés d'autoroutes
ensuite le président de la république de
l'époque avait décidé de faire un plan
de relance autoroutier pour soutenir
l'activité qui prenaient du temps avec
des notifications à bruxelles et puis
donc était arrivé cet avis de l'autorité
de la concurrence sur la rente
autoroutière donc on était dans un
contexte particulièrement tendu dans
lequel il avait compris un travail
parlementaire pour regarder s'il y avait
ou pas une rente autoroutières ou une
sur rentabilité des concessions et c'est
dans ce contexte là que s'était engagé
dès
discussion avec les sociétés pour
arriver à solder ces différents éléments
l'augmentation de la redevance domaniale
débouchant potentiellement sur un
contentieux avec les sociétés
concessionnaires la volonté du président
de la république de l'époque d'arriver à
boucler un plan de relance autoroutier
qui étaient engagés dans les discussions
avaient été engagées largement
antérieurement et cet avis de l'autorité
de la concurrence expliquant qu'il y
aurait une sur rentabilité des contrats
donc dans ce contexte la ministre de
l'époque a en effet décidé un gel des
tarifs autoroutiers
alors ce que vous pointez comme question
c'est un peu de savoir comment
fonctionne un gouvernement ça peut être
effectivement d'abord des réunions
interministérielles et les ministres qui
vont porter la parole c'est une façon de
faire et puis il ya d'autres moments où
c'est un ministre qui considère que
c'est sa responsabilité d'annoncer une
décision est ensuite voilà je reste
reste du gouvernement en prend acte et
c'est ce qui s'est passé à l'époque
non c'est la question qu'il y avait
trois questions non c'est pas ma
deuxième intervention encore maintenant
mais la 3 la troisième partie c'était
votre rôle dans le dans les discussions
autour du protocole les négociations
qui effectivement été entamées
auparavant pas avec ce plan de relance
autoroutier cette volonté d'avoir un
plan de relance autoroutier que
confidences commencer comment ça s'est
passé quel a été votre rôle de quelle
façon vous avez tenu informé la ministre
à l'époque et est ce que vous considérez
que ce protocole la signature de ce
protocole était une bonne affaire pour
l'état il est d'usagé
alors donc comme je le dis donc c'est
effectivement nous étions dans une
situation de relations très tendues avec
les sociétés concessionnaires
du fait de ce que j'évoquais c'est à
dire cette décision d'augmenter une
redevance domaniale une contestation de
la part des sociétés d'autoroutes qui
réclamait la compensation de cette
redevance domaniale la volonté du
président de la république de l'époque
monsieur françois hollande de faire
aboutir un plan de relance autoroutier
une décision la ministre de l'écologie
de l'époque de geler les tarifs
un rapport de l'autorité de la
concurrence et un groupe de travail
parlementaire donc à un moment donné il
est apparu utile d'essayer de trouver un
chemin un protocole d'accord pour solder
ses différentes difficultés
l'idée étant à la fois de solder les
litiges et de prendre appui aussi sur le
pignon exprimées par l'autorité de la
concurrence sur les travaux du groupe de
parlementaires qui était en place et
aussi sur un certain nombre de
recommandations ou d'indications qui
avait été donné par la commission
européenne suite à la notification du
plan de relance autoroutier et donc
c'est ce protocole effectivement
qu'il s'agissait de mettre au point pour
traiter l'ensemble de ces sujets a été
discuté à l'époque en tant que
directrice de cabinet de la ministre
avec le directeur de cabinet du ministre
de l'économie de l'époque et avec bruno
angles que je crois vous avez eu
l'occasion d'auditions et qui avait été
désigné par les sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute pour
représenter leurs intérêts dans cette
discussion
qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire de ce
protocole d'abord que nous avons
souhaité qu'ils permettent de mettre en
oeuvre les différentes recommandations
des rapports de la cour des comptes de
l'autorité de la concurrence et du
groupe de travail parlementaire ainsi
que les engagements qui ont été pris
auprès de la commission à l'occasion de
la notification du plan de relance
autoroutier ce qui veut dire que en même
temps que cet accord dans la foulée dans
le cadre de la loi dite macron a été
prévu la mise en place d'une autorité de
contrôle des concessions autoroutières
avec des nouveaux pouvoirs un des
pouvoirs donnés à cette autorité de
régulation de rendre des avis publics
sur les projets de contrats et avenants
sur la rentabilité du secteur de façon
générale et puis cette autorité donc qui
s'appelait l'art affaire qui est devenu
entre temps l'alerté a également un
pouvoir de contrôle des marchés passés
par ces sociétés d'autoroutes
effectivement ce protocole je pense
qu'il est le fruit d'un long processus
de rééquilibrage des relations entre les
entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires
la décision de gel des tarifs a pas
facilité la discussion du protocole 1
qui est intervenu au milieu de sa
discussion
grosso modo moi je pense qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que le bilan du protocole
est sans conteste positif parce qu'il a
permis d'éviter des procédures de
litiges qui aurait imposé un encas
blement à l'état enfin qui aurait été
forcément défavorable à l'état le
protocole n'a pas pu empêcher le report
du gel des tarifs de 2015 sur des
hausses de tarifs dans les années
futures qui vont qui courent donc
jusqu'en 2023
donc je redis ça veut dire que quand on
s'exonère de l'application d'un contrat
ensuite il faut en tirer les
conséquences
mais je pense qu'il a aussi produit des
effets positifs
monsieur me donne les évolutions de
tarifs mais je pense qu'on pourra vous
les faire parvenir ce protocole a
produit des effets positifs dans le
rééquilibrage des relations entre les
sociétés entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires
par exemple dans la négociation du
nouveau plan d'investissement
autoroutier conclu en 2018
on a pu s'appuyer sur l'avis devenue
devenue obligatoire dollar à faire ce
qui a permis de revoir à la baisse les
conditions financières du plan
et puis je pense qu'il ya eu des
avancées aussi importante dans ce
protocole
d'abord l'insertion d'une clause de
plafonnement de la rend type rentabilité
d avenant permettant de réduire leur
durée en cas de surprofits l'absence de
compensation de la taxe destinée à
financer leurs affaires le versement
d'une contribution volontaire des
sociétés d'autoroutes inde d'un montant
d'un milliard d'euros
et puis la mise en place de mesures
commerciales ciblées celle qui me
semblent importantes que j'évoquais pour
les jeunes les étudiants les
covoitureurs les véhicules électriques
et puis donc des engagements sur des
aménagements
notamment pour favoriser la pratique du
covoiturage et le développement des
cards imac rond et puis également la
possibilité pour l'état de d'être
présent d'assister au conseil
d'administration de ces sociétés
privatisées donc moi je pense que
l'objectif qui était de de solder les
litiges en cours et de pouvoir permettre
un premier équilibrage des contrats a
bien été atteint au travers de ce
protocole
quant à votre question sur ce que ce que
ségolène royal a été informé je pense
que peut-être vous connaissez la
personnalité de ségolène royal c'est
quelqu'un qui suit de près ces dossiers
donc je vous confirme qu'elle était
évidemment informés et qu'elle a même
pris en main on va dire la finalisation
de la discussion avec les sociétés
concessionnaires à la fin
merci de vos réponses madame la ministre
avant de passer la deuxième partie du
questionnaire du rapporteur
vous avez évoqué un déséquilibre dans la
relation contractuelle entre les
concédants et le concessionnaire pouvait
un peu préciser parce que c'est les
concessionnaires nous dise un peu le
contraire qu'ils ont la perception d'une
relation complètement déséquilibré
plutôt en faveur du concédant
vu qu'ils pourraient être rassurant vu
du concédant non en fait je pense que la
relation
je pense que l'inde et des défauts de
ces contrats dont je rappelle qu'ils
remontent enfin quand même imaginer ce
que c'est que de devoir gérer
aujourd'hui des actifs aussi important
aussi important en volume est aussi
important dans le quotidien des français
qui sont évidemment sensible au prix du
péage sur la base de contrats
conçu dans les années 60 donc ça montre
quand même la limite de cette pratique
de prolongement on voit bien que ça
pouvait intéresser tout le monde puisque
c'était une façon de faire faire des
travaux sans avoir à mettre des crédits
budgétaires mais le résultat de tous ces
avenants d'adossement puis enfin de la
pratique da doucement puis des avenants
fait qu'on est en train d'exécuter
aujourd'hui des contrats qui ont été
conçus dans les années 60 70
moi je suis convaincu que enfin vous
avez évoqué mes fonctions chez eiffage
j'ai également été pdg de la ratp ça je
pense que vous l'avez en tête
j'ai eu l'occasion de négocier des
délégations de service public avec des
autorités organisatrices un peu partout
dans le monde les contrats l'île sont
bardées de clauses qui permettent à
l'autorité organisatrice de demander des
comptes rendus qui permettent à
l'autorité au concédant des clauses de
rendez vous ces principes
la plupart des actifs régulés c'est le
paradoxe en fait finalement que ce
modèle concessif qui a été inventé en
france donc on l'a dit en 1955 a fait
école dans beaucoup de pays
mais évidemment les contrats tels qu'on
les passe aujourd'hui donne beaucoup
plus de levier au concédant pour pouvoir
garantir
enfin je dirais à tout le monde à
l'opinion publique au parlement qu on a
bien des clauses qui permettent de
réexaminer par exemple tous les cinq ans
la rentabilité d'un contrat et à défaut
de recalés des trajectoires tarifaire
pour s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas une
rentabilité qui excéderait ce que le
concernant a souhaité au départ
merci le ministre deuxième série de
questions vincent delahaye et ensuite
j'aurai éric bocquet et alain fouché qui
merci demandé la parole
merci monsieur le président de leur
donner cette possibilité d'avoir une
deuxième série de questions
donc effectivement on s'est aperçu et on
en a bien conscience que il y a eu des
améliorations sensibles depuis 2015 et
même récemment à la fois dans le suivi
et dans les nouveaux contrats dont tout
ce qui est nouvelle concession c'est
vrai que on s'aperçoit que ça a bien
évolué et qu'on tient compte
effectivement de l'expérience passée ça
je pense que c'est une évidence
alors juste je suis à la fois revenir un
petit peu sur protocole 2015 et puis sur
l'avenir ce que c'est l'avenir aussi qui
nous intéresse donc il n'ya pas que le
passé mais son protocole 2015
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec le
chiffrage de l'autorité de régulation
des transports la rt qui dit que le gel
des tarifs de 2015 qui a été compensée
de 2019 et 2023 avec des sur
augmentation parce qu'il ya eu des
augmentations plus importantes sur ces
années là pour compenser le fait qu'on
ait gelé les tarifs à l'époque
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec leurs
chiffres à ce qui fait que selon selon
cette autorité
on a les usagers au ps auront payé en
2023 et puis à la fin de la concession
500 millions de plus que ce qu'ils
auraient dû payer si on avait maintenu
simplement les augmentations en 2015 et
les augmentations normal tout au long il
ya une usure augmentation assure coup je
dirais à payer est ce que vous avez
aussi souvenir de la façon dont s'est
passée la négociation sur les taux
d'actualisation parce que dans l'
équilibre des avenants ou des protocoles
il ya bien sûr le taux d'actualisation
des flux futurs qui est important et à
l'époque je crois que les services de
l'état proposait 6,8 pour cent ce qui
est un chiffre qui peut être discutable
aussi et que au final on s'est aperçu
que dans le protocole c'était 8%
donc c'est vrai que pour la contrepartie
c'est pas la même chose si on calcule à
6,8 ou à 8% et donc a eu pour cent bien
entendu c'est plus favorable pour les
sociétés concessionnaires
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui a fait
troisième question sur le protocole
c'est pourquoi ce protocole a été at il
été matt du secret parce que tout ce que
vous nous dites est plutôt que dans un
sens favorable pour les
pour l'état et pour les usagers est ce
que finalement pourquoi il a été tenu
secret pourquoi il a fallu pas mal de
procédures juridiques pour obtenir la
communication ce protocole ça a duré
deux ans ou deux ou trois ans à peu près
autant qu'ils soient rendus publics donc
je moi je
j'avoue que j'ai pas encore compris
pourquoi qu'elle était finalement de
cette motivation est là que les
questions sur l'avenir vous l'avais un
peu abordée dans votre propos liminaire
met effectivement en tirant les leçons
du passé
comment peut-on préparer l'avenir et
quelle serait votre décision pour la
gestion l'exploitation de ses réseaux
autoroutiers si les concessions
autoroutières au lieu de tenir à
l'échéance en 2031 2036 quoi de 2031
2036 si ça venait dans trois ans qu'elle
serait aujourd'hui votre préconisations
pour pour préparer ce renouvellement
plus plus rapide
merci j'ai le rapporteur madame la
ministre vous avez la parole pour
répondre à cette question précise de
nouveau merci monsieur le président moi
je n'ai pas fait le calcul
à la place de l'autorité de régulation
des transports je pense qu'on peut
supposer que leur calcul est bon c'est
quoi le mécanisme c'est que quand vous
ne faites pas l'augmentation à un moment
vous valez les bénéfices des eaux ce que
vous faites plus tard et rapportée à la
situation initiale avec un fameux taux
d'actualisation donc à la fin oui les
usagers payent plus alors paye plus on
pourrait aussi recalculé avec leurs
propres taux d'actualisation qui n'est
certainement pas le même que celle des
sociétés d'autoroutes et oui faire moi
je vous le redis je pense que on a eu ce
débat y compris quand j'ai été ministre
des transports que certains disaient il
ya qu a gelé les tarifs
je crois même que certains élus
aujourd'hui nous propose deux exigés la
gratuité des tarifs
enfin je veux dire soit les sociétés
concessionnaires décide de
renoncer à leurs droits je pense que
c'est rare qu'une entreprise y compris
vis-à-vis de ses actionnaires puissent
eux renoncer à ses droits soit quand on
demande quelque chose alors on donne
autre chose en contrepartie c'est le
principe du droit des contrats
donc je continue à penser que de vouloir
prendre des décisions unilatérales si
elles peuvent à un moment donné à
paraître valorisante
c'est contreproductif dans la durée le
débat sur le taux d'actualisation savez
c'est des sujets qui peuvent être
infinie évidemment le concédant à un
terrain à considérer que le taux
d'actualisation et peut être bas et les
sociétés vont faire valoir qu'il ya des
tas de risque qu'il s'agit de couvrir
il ya aussi des conditions financières à
prendre en compte sur notamment ce que
sont les taux d'intérêt à un moment
donné moi ce que je note c'est
qu'évidemment le point d'atterrissage il
a été sans doute quelque part entre ce
que demandaient les sociétés
concessionnaires est ce que préconise l
administration sur un taux d'au je
rappelle qu'il a été validé par la
commission européenne y compris en
examinant toutes les règles 20 toutes
les mains quand la commission de
européenne a eu à se prononcer sur ce
type de dossier elle s'est prononcée au
titre du respect des règles sur les
concessions et elle sait qu'on prononcés
au titre des règles sur les aides d'état
donc quand elle se prononce sur les
aides d'état elle s'assure que on n'est
pas en train de donner un avantage à une
société par rapport à ce qu'est voilà
les règles normales qui doivent
s'appliquer
donc oui enfin je je pense que vous avez
en tête que dans le programme
d'investissement autoroutier dont la
discussion avait démarré déjà dans le
précédent quinquennat et que j'ai eue a
terminé en tant que ministre des
transports on a fait baisser le taux fin
moi j'ai fait baisser le taux tel qu'il
avait été envisagé dans le précédent
quinquennat notamment en m'appuyant sur
l'avis de l'autorité de régulation des
transports
voilà donc ça montre encore tout
l'intérêt d'avoir une autorité de
régulation puissante qui permet de
challenge est aussi un le les taux
d'actualisation qui sont demandés mais
ce n'est pas une science exacte en fait
ces sujets de taux d'actualisation le
fait que au moment en tout cas au moins
j'ai engagé la discussion sur ce
protocole le taux a été validé par la
commission européenne
ça ne laisse pas beaucoup de marge pour
dire voyez ce taux est excessif
bruxelles va nous projeter bon tout ça
est une bonne méthode
voilà sur le maintien secret du
protocole moi je suis incapable de vous
répondre parce que c'est pas moi qui a
empêcher sa publication
je pense que ça peut créer de la
crispation ensuite je pense qu'on peut
aussi faire valoir que peut-être il ya
des crocs clause prothèse je pense que
c'est du côté du ministère de l'économie
qui avaient une réticence à rendre
public ce protocole n'est pas posé la
question pour tout vous dire à la
ministre de l'écologie de l'époque je
crois que l'idée qui avait été mise en
avant par le ministère de l'économie
c'est que c'est un caractère de
protocole transactionnel et que a priori
peut-être même que dans les termes du
protocole il y avait des engagements
réciproques de ne pas rendre publics les
termes de ce protocole
in fine et tout ce qu'il y avait dans le
protocole a été transcrit dans des
contrats de concession qui sont
parfaitement publiques qui ont été
examinés par le conseil d'état qui
ensuite ont été publiés donc voilà je
pense que c'est j'entends bien les
interrogations que
les directions des affaires juridiques
des ministères ont pu porter c'est
certainement un point de vue
juridiquement juste on voit que ça peut
créer de la crispation inutilement quand
l'ensemble des données du protocole sont
par ailleurs public voilà alors sur la
façon dont on peut préparer l'avenir
donc c'est vaste sujet je pense que la
première question qu'on peut se poser
c'est de savoir si on pense utile de
maintenir un modèle concessif ou si on
pense qu'ils aient la voie par défaut
que les services de l'état doivent
reprendre la gestion de en direct de ces
de ces sections d'autoroute
je pense que c'est important
effectivement d'avoir en tête que le
recours à ces sociétés a permis d'avoir
un niveau de service
comment dire échappant à des régulations
budgétaires qui peuvent se produire et
qu'on a de fait un réseau qui n'est pas
donc financé par le contribuable mais
par l'usagé qui est sans doute mieux
entretenu que le réseau non concédé donc
si on pense que c'est important d'avoir
en france un réseau assurant une autre
qualité de service ce modèle me semble
présenter un intérêt
ce qui est clair c'est que de toute
façon ça ne pourrait pas être enfin que
le principe même des contrats devraient
être largement différent puisque les
sociétés les contrats tels qu'ils ont
été conçus à l'origine les sociétés
concessionnaires ont pris un risque
trafic
aujourd'hui on est sur un réseau mature
et donc je pense qu'on est qu est dans
quelque chose qui devrait plus
ressembler un contrat de partenariat que
l intérêt de faim je ne vois pas quel
serait l'intérêt de rémunérer un risque
trafic qui est largement réduit par
rapport à celui qui pouvait être à
l'origine de la création de deux
de ces concessions il faut quand même
avoir en tête que de temps en temps le
risque de trafic
il se matérialise donc c'est ce qui
s'est passé notamment pendant la crise
c'est ce qui s'était passé après la
crise de 2008 où notamment le trafic
poids lourds je sais pas a chuté dans
des proportions considérables je sais
même pas s'il a rejoint le niveau qui
devait avoir aujourd'hui et les oreilles
voilà les médisants pour retrouver le
niveau de 2008
donc ce risque de trafic ce n'est pas ça
n'est pas simplement un concept c'est
une réalité qui s'est matérialisé après
la crise de 2008 et qui s'est
matérialisé très violemment
s'agissant notammment enfin dans la
crise actuelle où le trafic des vl a été
réduit voilà de façon extrêmement
drastiques
bon donc voilà tout ça pour dire je
pense que ça ne me semble une piste à
creuser
mais en tenant compte aussi de l'enjeu
d'acceptabilité y compris ce que
j'évoquais qui crée beaucoup de
crispation sur la géographie qui a
évolué et des centaines de milliers de
jeux de 2-2 de citoyens qui de fait
empreintes des sections à péage pour se
rendre au travail donc sans doute il ya
des sujets de périmètre à regarder mais
qu'on puisse garder des idées de team de
contrats de partenariat avec des
engagements sur des résultats en
appliquant aussi davantage des
principaux pollueurs payeurs ça me
semble une piste importante à creuser
merci madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur on passe ce passé à nos
collègues sénateurs
le sénateur eric bouquet va prendre la
parole en premier la parole eric oui
merci monsieur le président
d'abord une remarque que même la
ministre pas de procès d'intention dans
mon esprit mais j'ai eu un coup de fil
de votre cabinet lundi soir alors je
sais c'est une pratique que vous avez de
manière systématique quand vous allez
être auditionné pour me demander s'il
serait présent et quel type de questions
je souhaitais vous soumettre alors
autant pour une séance de questions
orales du mardi matin où des questions
écrites et je peux comprendre la
démarche mais là nous sommes à une
commission denquête et j'ai été un peu
interloqué je vous le dis sans
agressivité mais par cette démarche que
j'ai trouvé déplacés deuxième question
mais je crois que vous avez commencé à
répondre dans ce que vous venez de dire
une question très globale avec le recul
de 14 années depuis la privatisation est
ce que vous considérez que la
privatisation des autoroutes a été une
bonne affaire pour l'état et donc les
citoyens effectivement sur l etat les
sites rien c'est la même chose
d'un point de vue financier d'un point
de vue de la qualité du réseau
du point de vue de la transparence et du
point de vue de l'usager
alors chacun a ses options sur l'avenir
convient d'évoquer
mais bon la gestion privée des
concessions autoroutières n'est pas le
modèle universel absolue nos voisins
britanniques ont un autre notre façon de
fonctionner c'est géré par une entité
publique financée par l'impôt etc
c'est une question de choix c'est un
choix politique au sens profond du terme
mais vous avez de commencer à répondre
un peu ensuite sur votre cv j'ai sans
concertation que le rapporteur compulser
votre cv qui foisonnent en est
effectivement été interpellé aussi par
sept années passées entre juin 2007 et
juin 2008 comme directrice des
concessions d'eiffage donc ça peut pas
être anodin dans notre dans notre
travail vous comprenez aisément le
rapporteur là elle a évoqué mais est ce
que vous pourriez précisé quelles
étaient vos fonctions exactes dans tant
que directrice de la concession chez
eiffage
quelles étaient vos missions
pourquoi êtes vous parti au bout d'une
année enfin j'étais un peu surpris de
cette brève période une seule année
comme à ce poste important j'imagine
et voilà encore une fois pas de procès
d'intention mais si d'aventuré demain la
privacité privatisation d'aéroports de
paris
trouver comme candidat repreneur le
groupe eiffage quel pourrait être votre
position dans ces négociations ces
discussions puisque c'est directement
dans votre périmètre de responsabilité
est ce qui pourrait pas y avoir un
risque de conflit d'intérêts et dernière
chose on a évoqué le rapport de
l'autorité de la concurrence de
septembre 2014 qui a formulé des
recommandations très précises pour
améliorer les choses en matière
transparence et c est ce que les
recommandations formulées dans ce
rapport ont toutes été mises en oeuvre
par les autorités
merci bien madame la ministre je vous
cède la parole pour merci monsieur le
président je suis désolé que vous ayez
été choqués mais voyez on est en train
d'évoquer des sujets qui remonte à
l'année 2008 voire avant donc je pense
que mon cabinet demande sur quels sujets
vous voulez poser des questions si vous
voulez avoir des réponses précises
ce que je peux aussi ne pas le savoir et
puis vous dire que je m'en souviens plus
je pas sûr que ce soit vraiment la
meilleure chose pour les débats mais en
tant que ministre de la transition
écologique je peux vous assurer que j'ai
un agenda bien rempli
et si vous prenez aux bruits à brûle
pourpoint pour en parler d'un sujet d'il
ya dix ans ou 15 ans peut-être que je
vous ai répondu mieux si j'ai préparé
mais si vous préférez je vous répond
spontanément aussi faire je pas sûr que
mais bien sûr monsieur le sénateur et
j'ai tout en tête instantanément y
compris et et eric a été pris en compte
pour la négociation des contrats
je vous remercie de la confiance que
vous m'accordez
est-ce que la privatisation a été une
bonne chose je pense pas malgré toutes
les fonctions que j'ai pu occuper que je
sois la mieux à même pour en juger
sané ça n'est pas le ministère de la
transition écologique ni même le
ministère des transports dont enfin que
fonctions que j'ai pu assurer qui a
porté la privatisation des sociétés
d'autoroutes
donc ceux qui sont les mieux placés pour
dire si finalement les recettes que
l'état en a retiré son bien à la hauteur
de la valeur des actifs c'est le
ministère des finances moi je vais pas
me lancer je ne dispose ni des analyses
qui était fait à l'époque nous
voilà dur calcul qu'on pourrait faire
aujourd'hui ce que je pense que c'est
que dans le principe aux dates savoir si
c'est une bonne affaire
moi je pense que ça n'a pas été une
bonne idée je pense que ça n'a pas été
une bonne idée parce que je pense que ça
n'est pas banal dans un pays dans le
code de la voirie routière dit que
l'utilisation du réseau routier est en
principe gratuit mais qui peut souffrir
d exception sur des sections à péage
donc forcément ça pose la question de à
quoi sert le péage le péage y sert à
développer à entretenir l'infrastructure
mais forcément à un moment donné il sert
aussi à donner une certaine rentabilité
à la concession et je pense que sans
doute les automobilistes seraient plus
convaincus de l'intérêt du péage qu'il
verse si comme c'était le cas à l'époque
ce péage servait à financer par exemple
des investissements dans le transport
ferroviaire
donc je pense que ça ça nuit à
l'acceptabilité du péage et je pense par
ailleurs que pour le coup je suis
vraiment convaincu qu'il y a eu une
erreur de ne pas changer d contraint
avant d'en changer de change et des
actionnaires des sociétés
concessionnaires
je pense qu'on aurait dû à l'époque
revisiter les contrats avant la
privatisation alors sans doute on aurait
du coup de verrouiller davantage les
contrats et peut-être que on aurait
retiré moins de recettes
mais je pense qu on s'épargnerait tous
les débats qui sont intervenues depuis
sur la sueur rentabilité des concessions
ou le surprofits qu'ont pu faire les
sociétés qui ont
bénéficié à l'époque de ces de ces
privatisations
s'agissant de la qualité du réseau et du
service rendu aux usagers
je pense que pour le coup de ce point de
vue là ça n'est pas critiquable je pense
que le travail est bien fait par nos
sociétés concessionnaires qu'on a un
réseau qui est bien entretenu je peux me
prononcer dans le détail
surtout que j'ai payé votre question l
avance sur l'entretien de telle ou telle
section mais je pense que globalement
les usagers du réseau autoroutier
concédé français peuvent quand même
noter qu'on a un réseau qui est de bonne
qualité
moi je souhaiterais vous voyez qu'on ait
des aires de service de la même qualité
sur le réseau non concédé qu on arrive à
développer à la même vitesse des
infrastructures de recharge
aujourd'hui c'est pas très facile à
faire donc ça montre que ça peut être
utile d'avoir des acteurs qui ont un peu
plus de marge de manoeuvre de capacités
y compris à investir pour faire des
économies en fonctionnement ce qui n'est
pas complètement le modèle du réseau non
concédé alors ensuite vous me posez la
question de mon passage chez eiffage
je vous répondrai simplement monsieur le
sénateur soit on porte le modèle que il
ya deux mondes le monde de
l'administration d'état dans lequel tous
les amis tous les gens doivent faire
l'ensemble de leur carrière que les
ministres ne doivent jamais connaître le
monde de l'entreprise
c'est pas ma vision voyez je suis
persuadé que y compris je le redis pour
les fonctionnaires mon administration
je pense que c'est bien qu'ils aillent
voir de temps en temps ailleurs ensuite
évidemment il ya des délais qui sont
prévues par les textes
il faut les appliquer et mon passage en
2008 chez eiffage je pense que je suis
sur la question avait été posée dans le
journal comme ça se passe souvent
maintenant de là
la nécessité que je ne déporte ou non
sur l'attribution d'une place sur la
mise en concurrence de l'affection
concédé de la route centre europe
atlantique
je me suis tourné vers les gens dont
c'est le métier la haute autorité pour
la transparence de la vie publique qui
ont dit que non compte tenu du délai
passé vous savez on n'est pas marqué à
vie quand on a quitté des fonctions
qu'on a plus d'intérêt dans une société
depuis dix ans je pense qu'on peut
retrouver son indépendance de pensée en
tout cas c'est ma façon de voir
question sur le délai assez court dans
l'est que pour lequel vous êtes vous
êtes resté chez eiffage pendant un an
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui a fait
que vous êtes partis aussi rapidement
enfin on peut appeler ça pudiquement des
désaccords stratégiques avec le
président en fait c'était une époque où
l'organisation était en train d'évoluer
moi je suis arrivé sur voilà certains
contrats entre temps le président de
l'époque qui avait passé la main un
directeur général a décidé de se séparer
du directeur général et de reprendre la
totalité de la fonction donc moi j'ai
considéré que c'était plus le cadre qui
avait été prévu initialement
ces choses qui arrivent dans des
entreprises privées fait des accords
stratégiques bien merci madame la
ministre de vos réponses précises je
vais demander à notre collègue qui est
dans son bureau bien installer alain
fouché de ne poser ces questions alain
tu as la parole
en 2005 moi je siégeais déjà au sénat et
la privatisation des autoroutes étant
dans la majorité présidentielle
on n'a pas forcément mesurer toutes les
conséquences on n'a pas forcément
étaient informés de toutes les
conséquences je considère pour ma part
que c'est une erreur majeure
le monsieur de villepin était peut-être
un manque encore des rentrées d'argent
voilà les rentrées d'argent et tout ça
c'est qu'on doit les bijoux de famille
un petit peu puis à quoi voit les
conséquences
le deuxième point je suis avec l'aps
auprès des questions à vous poser 1 la
ministre notamment son parcours il faut
que mata connais j'ai connu comme l'un
des dix ans préfète de la région poitou
charentes
ensuite j'ai fait des rapports de la
sécurité dans les transports en commun
que je légumes notamment en ce qui
concerne le métro qu'on est ce qu'on
veut avoir des gens qui dirigent la
france qui viennent de la fonction
publique totale et qui n'ont aucun lien
avec le privé le trac c'est bien ça
des exemples catastrophique les gens qui
passent par les grandes écoles c'est
quand tu déconnes par l'ena etc
et puis qu'ils ne font que ça et qui
n'ont aucune notion du teri et n'ont
aucune notion d'entreprise et vous dire
que donne deux exemples dans le
département de la vienne
on a amené un centaure paris
sentant pas madame burns était préfète
et sans toit pas que les primaires c'est
vraiment c'est priver complètement
l'expérience qu'elle avait dans le
public puisqu'elle était sur ses robes à
pain charge et d'urbanisme la ville de
paris et qu'elle avait un réseau
extraordinaire qu'elle nous a permis de
dd a réalisé 2 sortants 1 en passant
par-dessus plein de méandres de
l'administration qui voulaient bloquer
tout ça ne s'entend pas qu'en pleine
campagne avec des parisiens des artistes
qui voulait pas ça deuxièmement
travailler aussi
six concerts de faire rapport sur la
sécurité dans les transports en commun
il très grande écoute notamment les
caméras boutons etc etc
donc je dis simplement qu'on peut pas
asticoter quelqu'un parce que il est
passé dans le privé et qu'après des
zones publiques
au contraire c'est une richesse par
babar que des gens du public au gérer la
france y en a marre de ça que des gens
passer d'eux est très bien ce que je dis
se dit je dis ce que je pense je connais
la personne je connais son honnêteté sa
probité et je dis que sur le fond c'est
très bien j'ai là bas à voir que les
parisiennes fonctionner un pull gris de
la france et qui ne connaissent pas ce
qu'est le territoire tu te souvenir eu
une ministre de l'aménagement du
territoire et de nabeul moins sûr
j'étais entouré de plein de conseiller
de jean-pierre raffarin arrêté vers tous
les conseillers autour
ils étaient tous deux panneaux et lui
aucun d'un programme donc de dire des
choses comme je le pense troisième point
question madame royal ont chacun connaît
lustres est plus particulier madame
royal souhaitait présidente de région en
région où j'étais et que naturellement
le caractère fait que souvent elle
prenait des décisions salle et que
là-dessus personnes pouvaient en
empêcher
autre point et a présenté un budget bout
maintenant dame bornes sont les
améliorations que j'ai essayé d'apporter
vous avait alors évoqué les demandes
formulées en maintien de bonnes
nouvelles bornes de recharge et c'est
parce que ces compagnies autoroutières
gagne pas d'argent
enfin madame ma dernière question la
question c'est parce qu'ils pouvaient
répondre et pour l'avenir
toutes ces ressources l'actualisation de
contrat ils demandent des années et ce
qu'on a une idée des coûts globaux peu
après présenté pour l'état en question
après avoir dire ça tourne deux points
puis je tenais à souligner parce que
j'en ai lu terrain voilà merci beaucoup
à l'instinct témoignages on vous
rappelle tout simplement que la madame
la ministre n'est pas du tout remise en
cause dans ses bottes dans l'honnêteté
dans dans sa probité et on connaît
effectivement ses états de service dont
les connaissons tous madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le sénateur je me réjouis que
vous soyez dans la vienne qui est un
département que je connais bien et que
j'apprécie et peut-être juste rajouté en
complément je pense que c'est très
important
enfin moi j'ai énormément appris en tant
que préfet de poitou-charentes et je
pense que c'est une bonne chose de ne
pas passer sa vie au sein du
périphérique
je pense que ça montre la réalité de ce
qu'est notre pays et je pense que ça
aide à prendre aussi des bonnes
décisions sur le pain ce patrimoine des
sociétés et enfin des concessions
autoroutières je pense que ça sera quand
l'état en reprendre à la propriété à
voir ensuite comment le gérera une
richesse ça doit représenter 150
milliards je crois 150 milliards d'euros
la valeur du patrimoine de ses cent
cinquante 150
voilà donc c'est effectivement
un patrimoine considérable ça pose la
question de notre comment dire des
moyens qu'on consacre a bien piloté des
concessions sur des enjeux aussi
importants
je pense que on serait en angleterre
puisque des modèles ont été évoqués sans
doute il y aurait beaucoup plus de
fonctionnaires avec beaucoup plus de
conseils pour faire ce travail
je pense que du coup quand je disais que
j'étais favorable à un régulateur c'est
que je pense que ça vient compléter les
ressources qui sont consacrés à bien
comprendre l'économie des contrats et et
à mener des bonnes négociations mais je
crois que au regard de l'enjeu que ça
représente
c'est vrai que si on se compare à ce
qu'il peut y avoir dans d'autres pays et
au delà de la qualité des individus et
j'ai entendu le président de l'autorité
de régulation demande et plus de
responsabilité mais peut-être dans des
termes et je tiens à le dire que je
trouve un peu blessant pour les
fonctionnaires de mon ministère qui gère
ces dossiers
je pense qu'on a des gens de grande
qualité sans doute ils pourraient être
plus nombreux et disposer de plus de
moyens
la semaine au ministre la parole
maintenant à olivier jacquin et ensuite
jean raymond hugonnet merci président
madame la ministre la question j'avais
l'intention de vous poser tes relatives
à l'avenir
ce qui m'intéresse particulièrement mais
votre réponse sur cet épisode 2015 me
laisse vraiment sur ma faim à la limite
vous êtes tranquille puisque vous étiez
directrice de cabinet donc non
responsable en tant que tel moi
j'attendais bien plus de précisions sur
les enjeux des négociations
quels étaient les les comment dire les
rapports de force
quels ont été les points finaux de
négociation et les arbitrages rendus à
quel niveau
précisément je pense qu'on est dans une
commission denquête on peut
contrairement à nos autres auditions où
il faut savoir interpréter non-réponse
et s'en contenter
les considérant que c'est un fait
politique dans cette commission denquête
j'estime que nous avons droit à des
détails ce qui vous a été demandé par le
rapporteur
tout à l'heure sur comment s'est passé
précisément cette discussion qu'elles
ont été je suis en train de me répéter
nos intérieurs jeu que vous avez
parfaitement compris la question la
question je voulais vous poser donc
second questions sur la prospective
je suis effaré de notre culture
administrative française et de son
incapacité en l'état actuel du droit des
contrats à opérer des contrôles
efficaces et efficients je parle là des
différents ministères on a un imbroglio
de
de responsabilité de deux
comment dire au cours d'une négociation
la discussion passe d'un ministère à
l'autre pour l'exécution des contrats
n'a compris que c'était la dgitm au
départ c'est bercy
j'ai entendu une responsables juridiques
de bercy avouer que elle estimé le
rapport de force entre le concédant et
les concessionnaires totalement
déséquilibrée en termes de droit c'est à
dire la puissance publique n'a pas les
capacités du contrôle et un ancien
ministre nous a cité le problème du
suivi des archives c'est trivial pour
des milliards d'euros négociés sur le
fait que les archives n'était pas gérée
de manière consolidée et qu'en face les
concessionnaires que votre expérience
vous permet de connaître et bien en joue
très largement et cette absence de
capacité de contrôle forte
on la retrouve encore aujourd'hui la
seule solution c'est d'externaliser
cents à des autorités indépendantes on
en a une de qualité mais je m'interroge
beaucoup sur cette culture du contrat et
l'idée de les pérenniser
sans avoir fait évoluer cette culture du
contrôle
je citerai un exemple qui est non pas de
l'époque vous étiez chez dans une haie
ca ou directrice de cabinet mais sur le
suivi par exemple de l'état des lieux
des concessions eh bien nous avons
appris que l'état des lieux qui devaient
être effectués ne l'était pas et les
points d'étape ne sont pas suivis
cc je ne comprends pas ça ma question de
prospective et j'en resterai là sur
l'avenir je viens de dire un petit peu
ce que je pensais de
de l'avenir mais dans la loi
d'orientation des mobilités sur lesquels
nous avons beaucoup travaillé madame la
ministre vous étiez au banc une idée
avait été émise porté par un député qui
s'appelle baril qui avait repris l'idée
de l'association des ingénieurs des
ponts d'un dispositif ferment
d'anticiper la fin des contrats de
s'endetter dès maintenant dessus pour
financer les infrastructures de
transport je voudrais vous demander
après la l'homme aujourd'hui dans ce
contexte ce que vous pensez pour
l'avenir de ce dispositif
et là vous avez laissé entendre que vous
étiez plutôt favorable un nouveau
contrat de concession plutôt resserré
mais je vous ai dit ce que je pensais
les capacités de contrôle donc comment
faire pour que le droit du contrat soit
respecté mais l'intérêt général
l'intérêt général dans des contrats
aussi déséquilibré financièrement elle
l'autorité de la concurrence la montre
et soit éventuellement mieux prises en
compte
mais merci olivier madame la ministre
qu'avez-vous à nous dire sur les
appréciations du camp de la capacité de
contrôler vous avez rendu hommage tout à
l'heure aux fonctionnaires donc oui
enfin je juge
je l'aiderai parole merci monsieur le
président je pense que au regard de
femme plusieurs choses d'abord il ya un
moment il ya des contrats dont je redis
qui date des années 60 ou 70 vous pouvez
mettre des gens aussi nombreux aussi
appuyé par des conseils que vous voulez
soit on considère qu'en france on peut
s'asseoir sur un contrat soit on finira
par appliquer les contrats ce qui est un
caractère assez frustrant mais la
réalité elle est là vous voyez donc je
pense que quand on interroge ce contenu
de contrat oui ce sont des contrats
conçu dans les années 60 70 et on ne
ferait plus la même chose aujourd'hui
moi j'en retiens et je dis ça je sais
que ça va agacer des concessionnaires
que c'est bien d'arriver au terme de ces
contrats ça veut pas dire qu'il aura pas
d'autres contrats et je pense qu'il faut
arriver aux termes de ces contrats
les soldes et est passé à autre chose
parce que sinon on continuera à traîner
ce péché originel de contrats trop
ancien passé avec des sociétés publiques
qui sont désormais des contrats avec des
sociétés privées et cette voix là toutes
ses interrogations et ses débats
continueront à revenir alors ensuite je
feins qu'est ce qu'il en est de la
rentabilité et je sais que l'autorité de
régulation des transports va avoir à se
pencher sur le sujet qu'est ce qu'il en
est de la rentabilité de la concession
sur toute sa durée
qu'est ce qu'il en est de la rentabilité
de la concession depuis sa privatisation
qu'est ce qu'il en est de l'opération de
privatisation et qu'est ce qu'il en est
de la rentabilité des fonds propres
investis par ceux qui avec des effets de
levier ont acheté à l'époque les
sociétés fallait les sociétés
privatisées je suis incapable de vous
répondre je pense que c'est des bonnes
questions j'espère que l'autorité de
régulation des transports pourra
répondre à toutes ces questions
je crois que l'autorité de la
concurrence que je pense que vous avez
auditionné à depuis
reconnu que sa lecture qui était je
prends un excédent d'exploitation une
année donnée n'était sans doute pas la
bonne méthode d'une concession la
rentabilité d'une concession ça ne
s'apprécient pas sur une année mais du
coup quand une fois qu'on a dit ça on
on doit donc je recherchais différents
indicateurs la rentabilité depuis
l'origine la rentabilité depuis la
privatisation la rentabilité de
l'opération de privatisation
voilà je ne suis pas en mesure de vous
répondre
et pour revenir
à la capacité des fonctionnaires je
pense qu'on gagnerait à s'outiller
davantage je pense que les
fonctionnaires ils font du mieux qu'ils
peuvent
qui font des contrôles sur place sur
pièces qui font des audits
est ce que ça pourrait enfin on serait
en grande bretagne on aurait beaucoup
plus de contrôle beaucoup plus de moyens
et beaucoup plus d'audit
voilà merci madame la ministre jean
raymond hugo n'est notre collègue je
voudrais avoir des réponses à mes
questions notamment sur la première que
je posais sûr que s'est il passé
précisément dans la négociation de 2015
et depuis que je reprend la parole vous
me dites on serait en angleterre on
aurait plus de moyens de contrôle dans
la loi nouveau pacte ferroviaire je vous
interrogez vous étiez ministre
vous étiez responsable sur le cassant le
monopole de ferroviaire de sncf de
combien d'argent vous alliez recruté
pour effectuer votre rôle d' état
stratège et garant je n'avais pas eu de
réponse à l'époque
et quand je parle je suis pas en train
d'accuser les fonctionnaires j'ai parlé
de notre culture administrative
française et du système qui prévaut dans
notre pays
quelque part votre réponse à ce niveau
mais me conforte dans l'idée que on n'y
est pas et que demain envisage un
nouveau contrat dans ce dans des
conditions comme celle là c'est pas
possible quand vous nous dites qu'on ne
connaît pas la rentabilité des
concessions autoroutières alors il ne
faut pas concédé on peut pas concéder un
objet dont on ne sait pas ce qu'il vaut
dont on ne sait pas ce qu'est ce qu'on
estime qu'il vaut ça peut pas marcher ou
sénateur me faites pas dire ce que j'ai
pas dis je pense qu'à un moment donné
quand on fait un contrat de concession
ça repose sur des hypothèses de trafic
ça repose sur des hypothèses d'inflation
ça repose sur des hypothèses de taux
d'intérêt bien évidemment les
fonctionnaires à l'instant t il quand y
mènent des négociations pour les
nouveaux contrats ils ont tous ces
paramètres
ils sont appuyés par des conseils et il
négocie ses contrats avec des outils ce
que je suis en train de vous dire c'est
que refaire l'historique d'une
concession qui date des années 60
ce qui est une question intéressante
mais ces concessions c'est devenu un ces
contrats de concession avenante et je ne
sais combien de fois pour y rajouter
d'abord des sections parra doucement
puis ensuite des travaux par avenant
c'est des monstres ces contrats ce sont
des monstres et quand on relira si on
essaie de jeudi que essayer de refaire
l'histoire de ces contrats qui ont
doublé durée et dont le périmètre a
considérablement changé
je souhaite bien du plaisir à ceux qui
vont se pencher sur le sujet et c'est
extrêmement compliqué et donc je pense
que cette méthode n'est pas la bonne en
tout cas n'est plus la bonne voie là
pour répondre à votre question je vois
pas bien le rapport avec la sncf je me
permets de vous le dire je vois pas bien
le rapport on est on à un opérateur sncf
réseau qui est un monopole et on a des
régions qui mettront en concurrence et
on a par ailleurs une autorité de
régulation du reste là même qui pourra
s'assurer que ça se fait dans des bonnes
conditions
sur le contre à 2015 je ne sais pas très
bien ce que vous attendez de ma réponse
je crois que je vous ai refait les
termes de départ à savoir un contentieux
pendants sur une augmentation
unilatérale de redevances domaniales un
plan de relance autoroutier qui était
qui avait été négociée qui prévoyait des
travaux qui avait reçu l'aval de la
commission européenne qu'il s'agissait
de faire atterrir entre temps un gel des
tarifs
la négociation est la visée et c'est ce
que fait le protocole acté qu'on allait
mettre en oeuvre le plan de relance
autoroutier est voulue par le président
de la république dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pour les concédants
en s'appuyant sur l'avis rendu par là
par la commission européenne avec je le
redis un des taux d'actualisation validé
par la commission européenne ce qui
n'est pas forcément la meilleure façon
de dire il va falloir négocier tout ça
de d'obtenir que les sociétés
concessionnaires ne partent pas en
contentieux sur la redevance domaniale
de traduire les conséquences du gel de 2
des tarifs décidée fin 2014 en 2014
pardon et puis d'obtenir quelque part le
maximum en profitant de la pression de
l'opinion
ce qui est le principe de ce versement
volontaire acceptée par les sociétés
concessionnaires
voilà et la discussion elle a porté
autour de ces éléments
merci la ministre sur le contrôle on a
quand même le sentiment depuis que
maintenant nous travaillerons de notre
commission denquête travail qu' il ya un
avant 2015
avec sans doute une relation
déséquilibrée mais avec un rééquilibrage
depuis 2015 sur notre capacité à évaluer
le contrat est et comment ils courent
comment ils et comment il est abordé de
des deux côtés en fait on a le sentiment
véritablement alors on n'a pas non
conclusions définitives mais qui lie à
l'avant et l'après 2015 dans ses
relations contractuelles
parce que c'est précieux enfin d'abord
que d'avoir introduit des clauses qui
disent que la durée de l'avenant peut
être réduite si la rentabilité est plus
importante que prévu c'est quelque chose
de très important je pense que la
création d'une autorité de régulation
c'est quelque chose de très important ça
donne un appui pour pouvoir mener des
négociations
je pense peut-être utile de préciser que
le rôle de cette autorité de régulation
il faut pas non plus se tromper de rôle
l'autorité de régulation elle est là
pour vérifier non je dis ça parce que je
sais que le président de l'autorité de
régulation est très intéressé par une
extension de son rôle et moi je défends
les régulateurs il le sait très bien
je suis pas sûr que son rôle soit juger
de la pertinence d'un échangeur
complémentaires négocier dans le
précédent quinquennat sur la base d'une
doctrine beaucoup plus sévère que celle
du conseil d'état là je pense que
l'autorité de régulation n'est pas dans
son rôle
je le dis parce que je vois aussi ce que
peut faire la creuse dans le domaine de
l'énergie
on a un régulateur puissant rodez qui
est très précieux évidemment pour faire
évoluer des tarifs pour nous aider sur
des appels d'offres sur des énergies
mais qui est bien dans son rôle là le
rôle de l'état du gouvernement de
l'administration est elle rôle du
régulateur qui doit être de guide est
justement de s'assurer de bon équilibre
de ses contrats et je pense que c'est
important que chacun reste dans son rôle
il ya maintenant je donne vraiment la
parole notre collègue sénateur jean
raymond hugonnet merci président madame
la ministre
il se trouve que je suis sénateur de
l'essonne et que depuis 20 ans en tant
que élu local
nous traînons ce sujet
tel un boulet un fardeau voilà le sujet
qui nous tient aujourd'hui et notamment
s'agissant mais vous connaissez bien ce
sujet du péage de dourdan alors si
j'étais jaloux bien mauvaises langues
non si je regardais les choses de façon
concrète je dirais que c'était pas un
péage c'est une tirelire et que ce qui
se pratique auprès des usagers est un
racket 7 ce péage est très clairement le
péage le plus cynique de la région
parisienne située le plus proche de la
capitale est sincèrement celui ci il
reste en travers de la gorge de tous
ceux qui l'empruntent
aujourd'hui mais ça vous le savez
parfaitement en revanche depuis 20 ans
maintenant que nous traînons ce ce
boulet j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'entretenir avec un certain nombre de
ministres et je ne vais plus les compter
ou de secrétaire d'état et je dois dire
sans flagornerie que vous êtes de loin
celle qui a la vision la plus claire sur
les choses et qu'il énonce en quelques
termes de façon très claire et la
l'instar fin a contrario de mes
collègues qui tout à l'heure vous
taquiner un petit peu avec votre
parcours
puissions-nous avoir chacun le même
parcours professionnel chers collègues
c'est certainement ces quelques
casquettes sur la tête qui vous
permettent d'avoir cette vision aussi
clair et notamment celle qui n'a pas été
citée que vous avez cité deux préfets
qui est à mon sens certainement en tout
cas en terme de défense des intérêts de
l'état
la plus forte vous avez dit les quatre
problèmes suivants l'acceptabilité du
péage c'est un vrai vrai sujet l'absence
de recalage périodique de la concession
parce qu'il est bien là le problème et
pas ailleurs la nécessité d'une
régulation forte et puis vous l'avez dit
encore une fois son sens termes
polémiques mais au moment où il ya eu
une privatisation il n'y a pas eu de
révision des contrats et ça c'est une
erreur majeure
je veux dire là aussi à mes collègues et
je le dis de façon encore plus encore
plus libéré
l'administration la fustigent pourquoi
pas mais l'administration quand on lui
laisse la bride sur le cou ou quand le
politique n'est pas à la hauteur
là il ya un problème parce que ce sujet
là il est politique il n'est pas
administrative pourquoi les contrats
n'ont pas été revus avant la
privatisation
ce n'est pas la faute de
l'administration mais du politique et
j'en parle à l'aise
alors ma question mais deux questions
elles sont très simples la première avec
la vision globale qui est la vôtre
qu'elle serait à votre avis
larchitecture de cette régulation forte
relativement précisément si vous pouvez
consacrer quelques minutes à cette
réponse parce que vous l'appelez de vaud
veut également donc je pense que vous
avez peut-être déjà vous l'avez ce qui
c'est mais peut-être de façon un peu
plus précise et la deuxième excusez moi
c'est le local qui pose la question
proposeriez-vous une solution pour
cesser ou atténuer le racket du péage de
dourdan qui sincèrement je peux entendre
qu'en france la signature de l'état on
la respecte une convention la respecte
et un contrat on la respecte mais alors
que notre pays traverse une crise grave
que notre pays tient à bout de bras des
entreprises sous le coup du déficit
monstrueux puisque le plfr 3 va arriver
on en est globalement à 500 milliards je
dit ça sous le regard bienveillant et
l'ombre tutélaire de saint louis qui en
termes de saine gestion s'y attendait je
pense qu'à un moment donné on peut
mettre autour de la table les grands
groupes qui sont ceux et
concessionnaires tout en respectant un
contrat mais en faisant comprendre qu'en
france on va arrêter surtout après un
épisode d gilet jaune de se servir du
contribuable comme d'une vache à lait ce
qu'ils aient tous les matins à dourdan
et tous les soirs quand les gens
reviennent du travail merci de ces
questions précise madame la ministre
des commentaires et des appréciations le
ministre merci monsieur le président en
fait la régulation elle dépendra de la
forme on choisira aussi pour les
contraindre
moi je pense que il y a des contrats de
ce qu'on appelle les contrats de
partenariat c'est à dire dans lequel il
ya une rémunération pour un service
rendu sur la base d'indicateurs de
qualité exigeants enfin je pense que ce
modèle
ce modèle est intéressant ce qu'il veut
pas nécessairement dire qu'il fait
disparaître toute ph puisque dans ce cas
là le le prestataire on va dire peut
très bien collecté pour le compte de
l'état un péage
moi je pense que compte tenu de la
maturité du réseau je ne vois pas bien
l'intérêt de faire peser un risque
trafic dont des proches un contrat dès
qu'on met un risque en le peg et je
pense que finalement des phénomènes
aussi atypique que la crise qu'on est en
train de vivre
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu la crise de
2008 finalement peut-être l'étape
pourrait considérer qui est en son
propre assureur il a intérêt à les
assumer et que ça évitera de payer le
risque de trafic qui serait donnée à des
futures sociétés contractualisant avec
l'état mais après on a des tas de
modèles dans le monde de contrat et par
exemple l'allemagne à des différents
types de contrats soit avec risque de
trafic soit simplement de contrôle de la
qualité de l'exécution par la société
privée
donc je peux vous assurer qu'ils sont
nettement plus riche que le niveau de
contrôle qui est prévu dans nos contrats
de concession aujourd'hui c'est des
indicateurs précis sur des batteries de
critères de qualité
pourquoi là comme on l'imaginait pas
dans les années 60 sur le point que vous
soulevez ça renvoie à ce que j'évoquais
sur le fait que les barrières de péage
elles ont été placées à des époques où
les modes de vie et déplacements
n'étaient pas les mêmes donc moi je suis
vraiment sensible et je pense que c'est
un sujet qu'on rencontre aux abords de
beaucoup de métropole qu'un certain
nombre de barrières de péage sont trop
proches des vins sont placés de telle
sorte que beaucoup d'automobilistes
doivent emprunter des trajets à péage
pour se rendre au travail ce qui quand
on voit bien que ça n'est pas facilement
compréhensible voilà donc je pense que
cette réflexion il faudra qu'on les en
tout cas il faut qu'on les en têtes pour
l'avenir
c'était le sens de ce que pour le coup
j'avais demandé aux sociétés
concessionnaires en termes d'abonnements
de consentir une réduction je crois de
30% pour tout ce qui faisait plus de dix
allers retours par mois voilà bon donc
c'est une façon d'atténuer le
désagrément
je pense qu'aujourd'hui enfin idéalement
on pourrait penser que il s'agit de vin
qu'on pourrait imaginer des modèles dans
lequel le trafic local ne quitterait pas
le péage tous les pays européens sont
confrontés à ce problème
la commission européenne a fait des
ouvertures sur le sujet qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui mais je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'important
si on veut pouvoir avoir des systèmes
ont fait payer les l'utilisateur en
transit en évitant effectivement le
caractère irritant pour les utilisateurs
locaux
donc je pense que c'est aussi des choses
qu'il faut qu'on creuse merci madame la
ministre avant de redonner la parole aux
rapporteurs
une petite question par rapport aux
propositions de la convention citoyenne
et 110 kg alors je veux pas le sortir du
contexte mais le 110 km/heure en est il
par un risque trafic ou un risque du
renoncement au paiement puisque en face
du paiement de l'acceptation du péage il
y a le gain de temps là est ce que vous
ne pensez pas info quelle est leur votre
regard on est loin d'avoir la décision
mais quel est votre regard sur cette
proposition de la convention citoyenne
peut-être vous redire mon souhait
vraiment mon attachement à ce qu'on ne
réduisent pas
les propositions de la convention à
quelques mesures c'est je pense le ce
qu'on doit à ces 150 citoyens qui ont
fourni neuf mois de travail acharné et
qui ont voulu vraiment porter une vision
globale de la façon dont on peut
répondre aux défis qu'il y aurait été
posée de réduire d'au moins 40% nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
pourquoi ils ont mis cette proposition
en avant c'est parce que les études ont
en tout cas ce qu'ils ont pu en entendre
et je pense que c'est bien le cas montre
que si vous baissez la vitesse vous
réduisez les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ils sont dans leur rôle de dire
voilà pourquoi ne pas utiliser ce levier
ils sont conscients évidemment il était
conscient dans la convention que c'était
quelque chose
voilà qui posait un problème
d'acceptabilité et c'est une des mesures
qui a été voté à 60 % alors ça peut
paraître beaucoup ça veut dire que c'est
vraiment des votes partager les autres
étant en dehors de celle qui a été
rejetée celle qui a été rejetée sur les
28 heures par semaine à plus de 90% donc
les citoyens sont conscients de ce débat
moi j'ai échangé avec eux ils sont
conscients que c'est pas évident mais
disent mais notre responsabilité
maintenant qu'on a pris conscience de
l'urgence c'est de faire des
propositions fortes
l'ademe pour répondre à votre question
et d'un point de vue strictement
environnementales et je suis pas du tout
en train de dire que le gouvernement va
s'appuyer sur cette proposition des
citoyens est en train de refaire le
bilan y compris en tenant compte des
éventuels détournements qu de ce qui
pourrait du coup se dire hey hey hey on
sait déjà on sait déjà sur le sénateur
fouché je sais bien que
il ya beaucoup de deux d'utilisateurs
des réseaux routiers qui chante des
autoroutes à péage pour privilégier des
itinéraires gratuit c'est comme ça qu'on
a fait le tour août à 10 et puis qu'à la
fin on a dû aménager la rn10 parce que
faire plus long faire plus long est
payant ça voilà c'est un peu dissuasives
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse
effectivement de toute façon attention
aussi à ces aspects là mais on aura un
bilan global de ces de ces éléments
merci donc je leur donne la parole à
notre rapporteur vincent delahaye merci
monsieur le président merci madame un
ministre pour vos réponses et votre
participation à cette à cette audition
dans le cadre de notre commission
denquête moi j'avoue que bon il ya un
certain nombre de points qui nous
avaient apporté qui sont intéressants
pour la progression de notre réflexion
et la réflexion collective parce que ce
qu'on veut faire ici au sénat c'est
participer à cette réflexion collective
et apporter des éléments aussi pour le
concédant pour le régulateur et tout ce
que nous a dit de se ressourcer sujet me
paraissent très intéressant à l'heure je
vois simplement bondir un tout petit peu
sur la question posée par mon collègue
de l'essonne jean raymond gionet et
insister un petit peu dans le sens de ce
que vous avez dit d'ailleurs sur les
trajets
professionnelle entre guillemets un peu
contraint souvent contraints et
effectivement le péage de dourdan est
sans doute un des péages de france des
plus contestables à 7
cet égard je n'ai pas fait le tour de
toutes les péages urbains dans soho cela
mais je pense que vraiment il a une
spécificité particulière et je pense ça
mériterait quand même qu'on regarde bien
avec le concessionnaire cofiroute ce qui
peut être fait par rapport aux personnes
qui sont amenés aujourd'hui à se
déplacer pour des raisons
professionnelles
à partir de là partir et qui sont
obligés de passer par ce péage quasiment
parce que sinon l'alternative c'est la n
20 et la n20 le problème de
l'alternative à elven sait aussi que
tous les poids lourds pratiquement
aujourd'hui passe par la n 20 pour
éviter le péage donc c'est quand même un
vrai problème dans la région parisienne
n'est pas le seul sur j'en ai beaucoup
d'autres mais en tout cas moi je tenais
à insister dessus on auditionnera
forcément l'association de pour la
gratuité mais peut-être que même si
c'est pas la gratuité qu'on est vraiment
et vous avez parlé de 30%
je sais pas si ça s'applique
bah si ça s'applique déjà moi moi je
suis un peu déçu vous pourrez lire aux
sociétés concessionnaires si vous avez
l'occasion dé revoir par le nombre
d'abonnés à qu'ils ont pour ce tarif
réduit soit que ces cent mille 100 mais
c'est alors ça monte lentement ils me
disent vouloir ça va être formidable
demain je suis un peu déçu et ce qu'il
faudrait aller au delà c'est un débat
c'est le seul cas un finalement c'est un
jeu c'est le seul cas où les sociétés
ont accepté un geste sans contrepartie